السنه دخان وصفارات انذار وصواريخ تشق
طريقها نحو هدف مجهول لكن الرساله معلومه
مئه الصواريخ من قطاع غزه نحو المدن
الاسرائيليه تخرق حاله الصمت والترقب
وتدشن بدء رد حركه الجهاد الاسلامي على
سياسه الاغتيالات الاخيره التي استهدفت
عددا من قيادي الحركه الاعلام الاسرائيلي
قال ان مئات الصواريخ انطلقت من قطاع غزه
نحو مستوطناتهم تصدت لعدد منها القبه
الحديديه موجات القصف الصاروخي المكثفه
جاءت كرددا سبق وتوعدت به حركه الجهاد
الحركه قالت انها مستعده لكل الاحتمالات
وهددت اسرائيل بما وصفته بايام سود في حال
تماديها
هذا الرد قابلته اسرائيل بغارات اخرى
استهدفت القطاع وبتصريحات لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو عن امكانيه توسيع الحمله
العسكريه على غزه
حاله من التوتر والتاهب والاستنفار فرضت
على المستوطنين الملاجئ وعلى الفلسطينيين
الصبر والتحمل الى حين الانتهاء من حمله
عسكريه تتصاعد الاحداث فيها نحو مصير
يتوعد به كل طرف الطرف الاخر لكن كما في
كل الحروب لا ينجاب الغبار عن حلبه
المعركه الا ومخلفا في اديمها ضحايا بين
المدنيين سلام المحاميد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات